[Music]
well the Department of Employment
training and Rehabilitation announcing
its undergoing a four-year modernization
to its system now it comes after the
agency had issues processing
unemployment claims at a time when the
state had the worst unemployment rate
now to the state nevadans are still
having problems at Dieter Joshua peguero
Joins us live in The Newsroom with the
issues Joshua good afternoon yes good
afternoon so we had two people reach out
to eat news now they received letters
from Dieter that they have to pay back
thousands of dollars to the state and
they're having a hard time getting
someone from Dieter on the phone to
discuss their case
every time I call back they hung up on
me they laugh on the phone hours on the
phone waiting through a queue I try to
explain them what took place can I speak
to a supervisor slam the phone down Joel
Perlman showed us documents from theater
claiming he owes the state nearly thirty
thousand dollars in these letters Dieter
states he wasn't eligible for pandemic
unemployment assistance which he
received last year Perlman says the
pandemic forced him out of work and he
didn't even get that amount from the
state I got health issues of my own so I
got a lot of issues going on and this is
tremendous stress Sophie who did not
want to speak on camera received a
letter claiming she owes fifty seven
hundred dollars number one is Christmas
time
what a way to hit somebody and then
number two
um I was working during the pandemic she
says she didn't get that amount in
benefits and can't get someone on the
phone to discuss her case I've been
calling all day I work from home so I
literally been pressing my button all
day long log and nothing absolutely they
tell you to press three and then they
put you on and then they hang up at one
point during the pandemic Nevada had the
highest unemployment rate in the nation
at 28 unemployed nevadans filing for
benefits overwhelmed Dieter leading to
several issues including fraudulent
claims and a delaying payments now the
state is investing 72 million dollars to
modernize the system which will take
about four years
I did reach out to Dieter a question to
talk to someone about some of those
viewers concerns we're still waiting for
a response reporting live in The
Newsroom Joshua progero eight news now